giappone si è mai state parcheggio qua
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono parigi siamo su gta
sono tornato perché volevo carteggiare
un pochettino ho scaricato una nuova
mappa team bike challenge non l'avevo
fatto l'ultima volta
let's do air france non si sparano cosa
di fico allora l'ultimo episodio è stato
molto figo queste ambulanze sono sempre
intelligenti ci sta mettendo una vita
per spronarlo non so se si è pagato cosa
fa una veloce spalle noche spa una
veloce hspa veloce ok va bene allora
siamo la madonna mi sa che sarà un video
un po più incasinato del solito però ok
allora sbagliamo nel sito la nostra bike
ragazzi io non so come non come ho fatto
a non utilizzare questa prima a quanto
pare è la mia moto c'è scritto proprio
fa vigente ai ragazzi per chi non
conoscesse bike challenge quello che ho
fatto una volta è una specie di gara ad
ostacoli l'atac si può fare o in
multiplayer nei singoli adesso sta
facendo tutte più il singolo dove devi
arrivare a superare determinati ostacoli
molto [ __ ] questa cosa devi avere
ovviamente la moto per farlo perché sarà
la volta non puoi fare perché è troppo
stretto lo spazio quella dell'ultima
volta è stata molto difficile
questa e quella dopo sempre allo stesso
autore vediamo cosa riusciamo a fare di
rai ragazzi che possiamo partire ci
provo perché non sono l'ultima volta ci
ha messo non ho fatto un subscriber
d'ora in poi gli abbonati al canale li
saluto anche nei video se capitano
grazie caro sei molto gentile l'udc air
france e non si riesca a fare qualcosa
di decente
la partenza è buona la partenza mi avete
suggerito che c'è la possibilità di
aggius mamma mia che altezza orribile
dhabi non farei mai una cosa del genere
neanche con le cinghie di sicurezza
parte che non potrei farlo perché non la
patente prova beh dettagli mi avete
suggerito che del fatto che ci sono
delle minimoto da poter utilizzare poi
proverò nel prossimo bisogna usare la
mini moto ma come passo scusami eh hai
fatto un errore di calcolo amico che
come faccio a passare di qua
c'era quasi arrivato lì quindi devo solo
scannare con un drago praticamente
corretto quindi arrivo quale faccio so
se la roma e poi scanno come tua sorella
morta ma c'è anche la funivia calmiamoci
che stavolta è già difficile già
l'inizio è un casino del piano fin qua
ci siamo visti girare quando fratello
ora scanna come un puledro con un
puledro come un puledro zio come un
puledro proprio così queste ragazze mi
sembra un pelo di fi e invece ce la fa e
invece ce la fa ce l'ho fatta
apre la rampa che figata no rega
fighissimo ok ho voluto fare il figo
voluto fare il figo potuto fare figo
nell'ultimo livello che avevo provato
ragazzi le pale eoliche facevano davano
veramente fastidio tantissimo avere
questo no perfetta la niente caprioli
davanti all indietro che sono cadeau era
meglio farle ragazzi vi giuro non ho
capito come ho fatto a sbagliare
stavolta è stata veramente incredibile
fin qua ci siamo
perfetto piano piano piano piano piano
per favore piano o cosa c'era di
difficile anche prima una cosa a posto
bene bene mi metto un po d'azienda e fa
resterà per dico la verità porco demonio
infatti perfetto piano andiamo piano
andiamo piano che se nomi sfracello come
il fringuello che devo fare fare cose da
fare qua devo saltare qua sopra
per cui ci sono delle rampe che hanno
capito cosa servono per domandare su
quest'altra rampa schivare gli ostacoli
fare il world rai doppiato da come ti
amo sharepoint sicuramente tra devono
let's golf ski maschile tutto schiera
tutto ecco e prima ho già preso sono
fatto per questo gioco proviamoci di
nuovo ragazzi che è veramente difficile
sta parte c'è perché c'è il wall ride
the world best sì
che non si ride ci arrivo
no ero quasi arrivato da un pezzo di
livello è stato bravissimo
let's go ci provi cc bravo gira e
perfetto perfetto perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto tutto giusto tutto
giusto tutto una sega giusto bravo bravo
o le sono stato bravissimo
adesso mi servirebbe un check poi
teoricamente ma non lo faccio perché
credo in me stesso e nel cuore delle
carte credo nel cuore le carte come yu
gi oh
[Musica]
vabbè che comincia a rivoli come dove a
devo passare da sopra voi siete pazzi
no perché mi sa che avrei dovuto
prendere tutto la veloce quindi proverò
a far così persone curiosità cavolo si
poteva fare invece si poteva fare se
andavi viola problema prendo pure in
corso che non sei stato mai indietro
perfetto
sono stato bravissimo ha fatto una
provata adesso teoricamente vediamo se
riesco a fare così
ok ok dai ci sei arrivato ci sarà dai
cosa ho fatto
incredibile ci sono no dai
era l'ultimo cavolo che sarà buona
questo era buono l'ha fatta bene peccato
era l'ultimo a me dai ce la posso fare
ci credo ci credo ci credo ci credo ci
credo ancora ci credo sempre gesù è qui
presente
ecco dai pc cresce o fatta pazzesco
attenzione ancora lui dovrei mettere il
check point ma non posso metterci quanto
non posso metterci point ma non posso
vado a dovevo andare lì perché i ragazzi
ho piazzato c'è poi lo piazzato ci si
prova
o
dov'è che quella fare ma come ci arrivo
la quando salto non lo vedo neanche
questo punto faccio così guarda questa
visuale qua vedo niente
la madonna eccolo arrivato porca vacca
per uno schifoso niente allora aspetta
c'è qualcuno ha suonato il clacson ma
c'è questa roba attenzione proprio a lui
proprio lui quota play e mentre c'è
questa visuale tra l'altro ho saltato mi
sa un pezzo perché deve arrivare l'ha
salvato gli utenti
va bene chi se ne frega ci arriva per un
niente dove vado
cos'è sta roba aiuto aiuto amici quando
crederci ci ho creduto
e bastata forse sì tensione proprio lui
vorrai di un casinò in casinò sto
facendo casino per fratelli non ci credo
ah ok ci sono cose non mi spiego ma va
bene allora piano piano piano piano
effetto perché bello che è la mappa
socialista è fighissimo
buongiorno a è successo due cose c'è più
gente di prima come possibile amici a
darglielo subito che venivano insieme a
giocare aveva giù aggiunge 18 giu 18
bravo dimmi se ti diverti tuo fratello
c'è un posto più tranquillo dove
potresti riposare lo sai è lo tema talpo
favor ma vince sito the passare
comprende necessito il passaggio quindi
necessito accelerare
già me la colpa non citato demi lovato
però sono cadute hanno messo una
barriera di karma cioè io adesso
costretto lucida libro poi muoio gricar
ma non entrerò mai
e invece sono entrato dato che segue la
polizia si prende temi che sono ho visto
cose amici miei proviamoci
ci riesco molto bene prossimo mammamia
meno male che avevo il casco se no
chissà che botta ok bellissimo bravo
sono stato bravo primo tentativo
credibile questo andando le non sta
accelerando di tutto questo sono fermo
facendo tutto lui infatti si vede porco
demonio poche basta parte ragazzi non ci
ha formati a farvelo fatta per miracolo
prima ci è andata di culo in maniera
estrema come fai
non ci credo ma piano piano qua piano
piano che ha non serve andare forte
quando serve andare forte progetto
perfetto però è giusto così
vediamo ecco questa è la vedova finisce
in acqua la mappa come si esce o il
finale la voglio con questa mi piace uno
slalom incredibile da fare e piano
bravissimo cosa ho fatto
ecco c'è un problema di sopra di onde
che cosa sono schiantato contro un honda
e ti sei lanciato dalla moto ok cose che
non hanno senso però va bene ragazzi per
aver finito teoricamente poi i fan dalla
sopra sono salito a sinistra in realtà
doveva andare a destra non ideale perché
sono da sinistra va beh
l'ultimo pezzettino sipro ci sono le
onde rega impossibile con le onde piano
non aspettare che le onde passi in un
casinò in mondo ok bene perfetto il
finale col tramonto è fighissimo
se riuscissi davvero e ce la fa poi
lascio con la moto ma la posso
riprendere ai prendi ok bellissimo
finale con tramonto le cosce l'ultima
cassa teoricamente ragazzi abbiamo
finito veramente figo veramente figo
finale romantico romantico per che
c'entra molto i ragazzi vi ringrazio per
ha visto questo video
fatemi sapere se volete altri video di
gta se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivete o abbonatevi e non ci
rivediamo non possiamo vita bella
ragazzi
[Musica]
ma